fue el último adiós a la reina después
de cuatro días en los que miles de
personas pasaron frente al ataúd de
isabel segunda en la parte más antigua
del parlamento británico el féretro de
la monarca fue transportado por 142
marines hacia la abadía de westminster
mientras detrás caminaban el rey carlos
tercero y sus hermanos la princesa anna
y los príncipes andrés y eduardo también
fue escoltado por william y harry nietos
de isabel 2a
la ceremonia fúnebre la primera de un
monarca británico en ser transmitida se
consagró como el primer funeral de
estado desde el de winston churchill en
harley a su difunta majestad declarar
una transmisión de su cumpleaños 21 que
se dedicaría a toda su vida a servir a
la nación y a la mancomunidad de
naciones rara vez se ha cumplido también
una promesa así cerca de 500 de los
2.000 invitados eran líderes
internacionales los ex primeros
ministros del reino unido david cameron
theresa mail boris johnson y la actual
premier listos también estuvieron
presentes la ceremonia de un poco más de
50 minutos tuvo lecturas y cánticos
religiosos y se escuchó el himno dios
salve al rey recién modificado para el
nuevo monarca carlos tercero
[Música]
poco después los restos de la reina
isabel pasaron en una histórica
procesión por las calles del centro de
londres hacia el arco de wellington muy
cercano al palacio de buckingham más de
6.000 soldados participaron en el
recorrido una vez en el coche fúnebre el
ataúd tomó rumbo a la capilla de sant
george en el castillo de windsor a las
afueras de londres lugar donde cerca de
800 personas presentaron por última
ocasión sus respetos a isabel segunda
allí finalmente la monarca más longeva
del reino unido- descansará junto a la
tumba de su padre el rey jorge sexto
isabel la reina madre y su esposo felipe
el duque de edimburgo